Ich bin der Leon Orlandianyi, ich
bin neunzehn Jahre alt und
absolviere gerade meinen
Grundwehrdienst bei der Garde
in Wien. Ich bin auch
hauptberuflich Schauspieler.
Das, weil ich im Ausland
aufgewachsen bin und durch
diese Erfahrung habe ich
extremst viele Charaktere
kennengelernt. Das wiederum hat
mich dazu inspiriert,
Schauspieler zu werden. Als ich
zehn war, bin ich nach Wien
gezogen und lebe seitdem in
Österreich. Ich habe in dieser
Zeit mein Land extremst zu
schätzen gelernt und deswegen
bin ich sehr froh, dass ich
gerade meinen Grundwehrdienst
absolviere. Ich absolviere meinen Grundwertdienst bei der
Garde und ich sehe sofort
extrem viele Zusammenhänge
zwischen Schauspiel und Paradeexizieren. Beim Paradeexerzieren
genauso wie beim Schauspiel
ziehst du den Uniform an und
bewegst dich in einem Rhythmus
und diese Erfahrung hat mir
persönlich extremst geholfen
und deswegen bin ich sehr froh,
dass ich ausgerechnet bei der
Garde bin. Man kennt mich aus
Filmen wie zum Beispiel
Meiberger oder Suko-Donau
hauptsächlich aber aus dem
Film, das schaurige Haus, wo
der Daniel Prochaske die Regie
geführt hat. Mit diesem Film
bin ich tatsächlich auch zum
Romy nominiert worden als
beliebtester
Nachwuchsschauspieler 2021
Es
würde mich etrems freuen, wenn
ihr für mich voten könntet
unter Romy.at/voting
Danke sehr.